[Music]
how do you handle the red carpet because
I think it's the one thing most people
watch an award show and think oh a red
carpet would be a lot of fun and what
they don't know is that it's a very
strange experience and there's a lot of
yelling it's weird I do very poorly at a
that the yelling is always very
uncomfortable but I also have these
incredibly light-sensitive eyes and
whenever I go it's always like this
stressful moment for me because all of
the light bulbs go off like kind of at
the same time and it's this like intense
bright light that makes my eyes water
and sort of gives me vertigo at times
and I get really stressed out on it and
my biggest fear is that after I leave
and it's the end of the night and the
you know photographer is going through
the photos they see my photos and I'm
just afraid that they're going to go why
is he crying good time he's sobbing he's
sobbing I've got single tear I mean you
could probably track a single tear as it
goes down my face well if there's also
the there's the hierarchy there's the
ranking it's very high school it is
sometimes you're faced with you know the
situation where it's it can be a
humbling and I've got one of those and
it ended up being the best the least my
eyes have watered ever because I was at
an award show and I was about to go on
the carpet I was very nervous and in
comes Clooney and he gets a free pass he
goes straight to the front of the lunch
line whenever he gets there and yet the
place goes nuts and I'm just staring at
him going that man is tan and he's
walking down that carpet and he
acknowledged that he cut you and lo he
did he was very polite he said sorry
buddy and I just went
it's sorry buddy yeah I'm being polite
right that's B that's a famous guy's
version of being polite but when you
sorry pal you lose yeah yeah he's so
nice as he does he steps on your neck to
get over you he was just so tan and he
could have said anything and it would
have worked yeah he went you lose I win
here I go he went down that carpet and
it was like an atom bomb of light went
off right by like anyone behind him I
hope we're wearing safety goggles yes
because it was the brightest white I've
ever seen and then I instantly felt two
things a I felt very I knew I was gonna
be a letdown right I knew I was like how
am I gonna be able to follow that but
then I got really excited because no
amount of bright light is going to
affect my eyes after that so I pretty
much had the equivalent of like one
firecrackers worth of light in
comparison to his atom bomb of flash
bulb photography going on myself no tear
my favorite moment like that was once in
New York and there was some event where
all the biggest stars and I wasn't even
going to that event I was just trying to
get to my apartment but all the all the
biggest stars invited you no of course
no oh the big stars were there you know
they're gonna let me in guys like me
come in the back window and all the big
stars were there everybody everybody's
there and just I mean literally insanity
Tom Cruise was like barely making the
list and it was just flashes and lights
and everything and I'm just trying to
get to my apartment I walked by and a
paparazzi guy sees me and he starts to
raise his camera and then lowers
[Applause]
welcome to too much too heavy I can't
waste digital space it's digital camera
I'll take it if you want no I I had a
moment like that once and Robertson
there's a street here in LA where like
you know Paris Hilton we'll go shopping
and there's always paparazzi and I saw a
bunch of paparazzi standing around
outside a boutique with their cameras
ready and I was on my way to the gym so
I was in gym clothes and I was walking
by and kind of tensed up like they were
gonna take my picture and two of them
went oh hey Andy
[Applause]